[Musik]
der power 2009 10 das wetter scheint
zunächst nicht mitzuspielen
die wolkendecke über zeltweg sie zu doch
das verhinderte den geplanten start um 9
uhr vormittags nicht und wird richtig
ist jetzt
wie werden die fotos waren super aber
wie viel angst hatte dass keine zwei
oberpfleger 500
perfekt
[Musik]
neo soul giganten er parat aber sogar
härter so ausschauen gäste er vor halte
ich glaube die geistige polizei
[Musik]
ja genau
der general und sieht doch schon den
ganzen vormittag habe daher vor 19
unterwegs ist schon ein paar eindrücke
mitgenommen die dann bleibt werden ja es
ist eine unglaubliche qualität von
leistungen von technik die hürde
publikum geboten wird sind also die
piloten des bundesheeres die hier ihre
leistungsfähigkeit beweisen die auch
nebenbei für den einsatz üben denn eine
flugshow hat keinen selbstzweck sondern
es geht auch immer um übung für schutz
und hilfe für die bevölkerung auf der
anderen seite sehr viel ziviles
interesse unsere zusammenarbeit mit red
bull und
das land steiermark ist altbewährt
funktioniert bestens
also es ist ein sehr wohl abgestimmte
ablauf der gut funktioniert und ich
glaube auch dem publikum sehr viele
positive eindrücke vermitteln wird
[Musik]